und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten haben wir
an diesem wochenende einen ausflug
gemacht hat konnte entweder vom 9 euro
ticket der grünen profitieren oder vom
tank rabatt der fdp so war zumindest der
plan jeder bekommt etwas für seine
wählerklientel und mit zweieinhalb
beziehungsweise 3 milliarden euro
steuergeld liegen sie auch ungefähr in
einer preisklasse allerdings ist die fdp
mit dem tank rabatt ja nicht so richtig
happy geworden weil eingetreten ist weil
es praktisch jeder ökonom voraussagte
der rabatt kommt bei den autofahrern
nicht eins zu eins an die frage ist
inwieweit die ölkonzerne die
steuerentlastung abschöpfen die fdp fand
jedenfalls der wirtschaftsminister müsse
da was tun und heute kommt harburg mit
einem recht brisanten vorschlag um die
ecke jan fritsche berichtet sie sind
dieser tage so etwas wie ziemlich beste
feinde finanzminister lindner der für
seine fdp den tank rabatt durchgesetzt
hat und wirtschaftsminister habeck der
aus sicht der liberalen dafür sorgen
muss dass der rabatt auch ankommt heute
hat habeck seine pläne vorgestellt das
war es als entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die verbraucher
die verbraucher gedacht war geht in die
taschen der großen mineralölkonzerne
dass man darüber sauer ist empört das
was nicht richtig sein kann ist völlig
klar und so will habe ich jetzt das
kartellrecht verschärfen auch ohne
direkten nachweis illegaler
preisabsprachen sollen die
wettbewerbshüter harte maßnahmen
ergreifen können etwa profite der
konzerne einziehen oder sie notfalls
sogar zerschlagen habe ich hätte sich
stattdessen auch den weg einer steuer
auf übermäßige gewinne vorstellen können
eine über gewinnsteuern streit über die
abschöpfung von gewinnen oder von über
gewinn den kennen sie ja natürlich geht
es auch über das steuerrecht oder ging
ist über das steuerrecht aber der weg
scheint jetzt verbaut zu sein verbaut
vor allem von seiner partei fdp chef
lindner lehnt die über gewinn steuer am
abend im zdf noch einmal entschieden ab
ich hoffe dass der vorschlag dieser
sogenannten über gewinn steuer damit vom
tisch ist denn
die würde unser steuerrecht der willkür
und den politischen
stimmungsschwankungen ausliefern der
adac lobt die initiative habe es statt
der versprochenen 35 cent preisnachlass
für benzin und 17 cent für diesel komme
aktuell viel weniger bei den autofahrern
an benzin sind es etwa 20 cent im
vergleich zum vor der steuersenkung und
bei diesel ist es noch weniger sind es
nur 5 cent also voll umfänglich kommt
der rabatt nicht beim verbraucher an
auch habe das ministerium verweist
darauf dass zwischen den rohöl- und
tankstellen preisen seit monatsbeginn
eine große lücke klafft der
mineralölverband sieht sich nicht in der
schuld
die energie steuersenkung wird
weitergegeben
unabhängig von der gesenkten energie
steuer auf benzin und diesel sind
allerdings weltweit die kraftstoffpreise
gestiegen nicht nur hier in deutschland
kritik an habe ex plänen kommt auch aus
der opposition
auch wenn kein missbrauch
begangen worden ist dass dann das
kartellamt eingreifen darf das wird
rechtlich so gar nicht möglich sein was
robert habeck vorliegt das reicht nicht
aus die regelung wird nicht dazu führen
dass kurzfristig preise sinken für
kurzfristige entlastung an der zapfsäule
dürften hwx pläne tatsächlich nicht
sorgen er hofft auf eine umsetzung noch
dieses jahr und so dürfte auch über den
tank rabatt das letzte wort noch nicht
gesprochen sein und das verhältnis der
ampel parteien angespannt bleiben
werden bundeskanzler scholz und emanuel
mack und tatsächlich nach kiew reisen
wollen werden sie das vermutlich auf dem
gleichen weg tun wie andere staats und
regierungschefs vor ihm per eisenbahn
eine offizielle flugverbindung gibt es
nicht mehr autofahrten gelten als
gefährlich abgesehen vom schlechten
zustand vieler straßen
die ukrainische eisenbahn ist
tatsächlich die lebensader des landes
ihr 20.000 kilometer langes streckennetz
verbindet groß städte und dörfer land
und küsste ohne sie wäre die ukraine
verloren menschen kämen nicht raus
waffen nicht rein dass die züge weiter
rollen ist längst kriegsentscheidend
geworden und das bahnpersonal kämpft
dafür so tapfer die soldaten an der
front
den chef der eisenbahn der in der
ukraine an regelrechten heldenstatus
genießt hat christian sievers heute in
kiew getroffen christian und unser
redaktionskollegen dara hassanzadeh
haben sich diese woche in die ukraine
aufgemacht und reisten von lemberg nach
kiew natürlich mit der eisenbahn an
diesen schienen hängt plötzlich die
zukunft eines ganzen landes wer hier
unterwegs ist kennt das risiko nur noch
maximal 80 fahren obwohl auch der
museumsreife zu 130 schaffen würde
nachts am besten ohne licht
[Musik]
russlands raketen haben speziell die
bahnstrecken zum ziel gemacht die
ukrainische eisenbahn muss seit beginn
des krieges um fast 200 toten trauern
unter den eigenen mitarbeiter
wir bringen menschen aus gefährlichen
gegenden in sicherheit wir bringen
humanitäre hilfe und die wirtschaft der
ukraine hängt an der eisenbahn
fast ein viertel des schienennetzes hat
der krieg bereits zerstört wo die bahn
noch fährt ist sie für die menschen
häufig das letzte verkehrsmittel das
ihnen bleibt die einzige verbindung zur
familie
freunden oder dem wochenmarkt noch vier
stunden bis kehrt
als der krieg anfang hatte ich echt
angst wir fuhren hier im zug und wussten
nicht was als nächstes passieren würde
und die passagiere fragten plötzlich
werden wir heil ankommen
weizenexporte in den westen
waffen an die front im osten die bahn
logistik entscheidet über wohl und wehe
was man aus längst vergangenen zeiten
und den geschichtsbüchern kennt es
plötzlich wieder ganz aktuell es ist
auch ein eisenbahn krieg
und er rückt ein mammut unternehmen in
den mittelpunkt das bislang höchstens
belächelt wurde wo fast 5000
bahnübergänge so aussehen jemand mit
warnweste und gelbem fähnchen
im schrankenwärter haus samt
gemüsegarten
unsere reise hat in lemberg begonnen
rettender bahnhof für die verletzten und
versehrten aus dem osten des landes
zwölf lange stunden war dieser sonderzug
unterwegs immer noch schneller als ein
rettungswagen auf den kaputten straßen
und für den wäre nicht mal genug sprit
da
angeschaut und haben uns jetzt den
krediten für uns mit geholt hat ein
schweres schädel-hirn-trauma erlitten
nach einer explosion verletzung ist im
moment stabil ist aber verwirrt wir
sprechen da von dem delia heißt die
probleme gemacht hat und deswegen können
wir denn jetzt ins notfall krankenhaus
als erstes haben den rausgeholt
wir haben sauerstofftanks wir haben
beatmungsgeräte der zug ist eine
großartige idee die lokalen helfer hier
sie sind so stolz dass es sowas gibt
weil man wirklich fühlt welche not hier
herrscht
wo genau der zug hält muss geheim
bleiben die helfer befürchten dass
selbst die denen der krieg fast alles
genommen hat nochmal zum ziel russische
angriffe werden könnten
lemberg hauptbahnhof gleis 3 die einen
sind auf dem weg an die front die
anderen haben von allem längst genug so
viele geschichten auf einem bahnsteig
das sieht aus wie ein normales treiben
und ist doch schwer zu begreifen
diese normalität fühlt sich wirklich
seltsam hier in dieser stadt spürt man
nicht wirklich dass krieg ist mit all
den grausamkeiten und diesem unsagbaren
horror hier ist alles so schön gucken
sie sich diese stadt an jeder wird
fröhlich aber ich merke dass der schmerz
ganz tief sitzt
familie der genau wie auf dem weg zurück
nach hause sie waren nach tschechien
geflohen und haben es nicht mehr
ausgehalten vor heimweh
im moment ist unser haus und die daneben
noch intakt aber es gibt kaputte häuser
im dorf das dorf ist jetzt in zwei teile
geteilt das alte und das neue das jetzt
komplett zerstört ist
ein wenig hoffnung und ganz viele sorgen
fertig ist erst 2 er spürt dass seine
familie in not ist und er spürt dass er
jetzt besonders viel trost braucht
seit zwei tagen ist die familie bereits
unterwegs 12 stunden liegen noch vor
ihnen mit dem zug einmal quer durch die
ukraine
und dann schalten wir zur christian
sievers in kiew hallo christian
hallo maria ihr seid gestern in kiew
angekommen was sind deine ersten
eindrücke aus der stadt
ja maria ittermann man ist hier hin und
hergerissen das ist auf der einen seite
eine echte sommer metropole gerade bei
diesem heißen wetter jetzt im moment die
das leben feiert ist erinnert so ein
bisschen an tel aviv in manchen momenten
dieser jetzt erst recht modus den man
ihr zu spüren scheint die cafés sind auf
jeden fall voll die straßen war es auch
die restaurants auf den speisekarten
ukrainische fusion küche mit
überraschendem twist und die scooter
parken hier alle ganz ordentlich
aufgereiht am straßenrand aber dann
natürlich die andere seite man spürt die
sorgen man merkt sofort wenn man mit den
menschen redet wie viel sorgen sie haben
man merkt in dem moment in dem man die
kamera auspackt dann sofort die polizei
fragen stellt und dann wenn es dunkel
wird und die sperrstunde kommt und
manchmal dazu auch noch alarmsirenen ein
luftalarm und die stadt dann ganz leer
und leise wird und band was wohl kommen
mag was er in seiner reportage auch
wirklich eindrücklich gesehen haben ist
dass die eisenbahn wirklich diese
lebensader ist das ist die unbedingt
braucht und du hast uns erzählt dass ihr
chef in der ukraine quasi so eine art
nationalheld ist
das ist ja auf jeden fall wird auch
ständig angesprochen darauf erhört ist
allerdings nicht sehr gerne und das
obwohl er schon seit monaten kaum noch
zu hause war erfährt aus
sicherheitsgründen mit einem eigenen
schlafwagen hier quer durchs land der
wird immer an so ein zug angehängt und
haben ändert dann seinen aufenthaltsort
weil so heißt es der russische
geheimdienst hinter ihm her ist und er
bei denen auf einer liste steht er muss
also sehr aufpassen der mann managt das
mit abstand größte unternehmen dieses
landes mit etwa
230.000 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern ein unternehmen das quasi
über nacht auch zum wichtigsten
unternehmen der ukraine geworden ist und
gleichzeitig zum ganzen stolz seiner
menschen und zu einem symbol für
widerstand ich habe mit ihnen heute
gesprochen und zwar in der business
launch der ukrainischen eisenbahnen hier
am hauptbahnhof in kiel
so alexandra konicek very much
verbringen das sei für die einladung sie
sind 37 jahre alt wenn ich das sagen
darf sie sehen jetzt auf den ersten
blick nicht unbedingt aus wie der
typische bahnmanager sie leiten das
größte mit abstand größte unternehmen
der ukraine im moment nach sechs monaten
im job kam der krieg was mussten sie
ändern um das zu bestehen um dadurch zu
kommen
first days on the way to make was in den
ersten tagen des krieges muss man
schnell entscheiden und verantwortung
übernehmen man muss schnell reagieren
und handeln während der ersten 100 tage
muss man vorhersagen treffe man muss
regeln aufstellen und man muss
protokolle einrichten oh ja und jetzt
sind wir bei den zweiten 100 tagen des
krieges und es geht neue
herausforderungen you have to predict
wort betrat man muss voraussagen was in
einem jahr passieren wird und
man muss dann entsprechend sich
vorbereiten und man muss ein team
einrichten das in der lage ist
entsprechend dann auch zu reagieren und
das unternehmen unter neuen bedingungen
zu leiten in der geschichte war es
häufiger so dass kriege tatsächlich auch
dadurch entschieden wurden welche seite
am ende die bessere eisenbahn logistik
karte glauben sie dass auch dieser krieg
auf den schienen entschieden wird am
ende in die trotz textes important die
logistik ist sicherlich richtig aber ich
möchte die bedeutung der logistik nicht
überstrapazieren wenn wir siegreich
diesen krieg beendet haben werden wir
uns zusammensetzen und entscheiden was
wichtiger war sicherlich ist die armee
die nummer eins aber manche sagen dass
die eisenbahnen die armee nummer zwei
sind wir sind vergleichbar was die
mitarbeiter angeht und sicherlich in
gewissem umfang auch wichtig jetzt ist
es so dass ich auch viele politiker auf
die ukrainische eisenbahn verlassen der
letzten zeit gerade aktuell die eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen
spanische aussenminister der deutsche
oppositionsführer friedrich merz alle
sind mit ihnen gefahren auf der anderen
seite müssen sie versuchen die blockade
der häfen irgendwie auszugleichen die
exporte der ukraine jetzt auch via
eisenbahn nach draußen zu bekommen die
getreideexporte zum beispiel das essen
das getreide für die welt wie viel
unterstützung erwarten sie denn da vom
westen auch gerade von deutschland euro
von airbus oder ob alle unsere nachbarn
und partner auch deutschland sind sehr
hilfreich aber wir brauchen mehr denn
wenn wir über getreide sprechen
exportierende im moment 1,2 millionen
tonnen als ganzes land einschließlich
der eisenbahnen wir müssen aber fünf
millionen tonnen exportieren also
viermal soviel und mehr getreide kommt
mit der neuen ernte also 200 km der chef
der ukrainischen staatsbahn
bekamen krieg danke dass sie gekommen
sind
ja der unorthodoxe manager hat jetzt ein
sechsköpfiges führungsteam für den krieg
aufgestellte im moment dass diese mammut
konzern lenken soll er sagt da sind drei
junge leute dabei direkt aus der
business school aus singapur aus den usa
und dann auf der anderen seite drei
eisenbahner mit insgesamt 95 jahren
erfahrung und er sagt das ist so wenn
man durch die tür will dann sagt er dann
kommen die jungen und die brechen die
tür einfach erst mal auf und die alten
sagen immer mit der ruhe wir wissen
jetzt bereits was dahinter ist nun
beides zusammen bringt so sagt der
bahnchef kann man ein unternehmen
erfolgreich managen und marietta das
vielleicht noch alexander k maschinen er
glaubt dass dieser krieg noch jahre
dauern wird und er sagte uns er versucht
sein unternehmen darauf vorzubereiten
seine familie und auch sich selbst
christian bisschen kiew weitere sehr
interessante gesprächspartner haben und
wir werden dann auch wieder ein teil des
heute journals mit die direkt aus kiew
senden alles gute bis dahin bis morgen
ja und russland wie wird der krieg in
moskau oder st petersburg gesehen
jenseits der abendlichen propaganda show
im staatsfernsehen auf eine
generalmobilmachung bei der jeder
eingezogen werden kann hat putin bislang
verzichtet die meisten seiner soldaten
kommen bisher aus der republik dagestan
im nordkaukasus
kaukasus oder aus der zentralasiatischen
region um den baikalsee das sind
ärmliche landstriche fernab von moskau
wie viel ist der hauptstadt von krieg
und sanktionen überhaupt schon zu spüren
axel sturm berichtet dass moskau
als sich der pianist lukas affront noch
im märz an seine lieblings mcdonald's
filiale in moskau kettet hat er nicht
nur hungern heute hat mcdonald's
beschlossen sich abrupt von mir zu
trennen aus irgendeinem grund und auch
andere wollen uns verlassen wir haben
doch immer gutes geld für den service
gezahlt
saffron aus gastspiel währt nur kurz
natürlich wird er abgeführt und die ära
mcdonald's geht trotzdem zu ende wandel
durch frittenfett und bürger gescheitert
rosanna hingegen sieht heute ihre stunde
gekommen am morgen neueröffnung der
moskauer filiale presse kameras
interviews hungrige kunden auch ein
symbol dieses event es wird weitergehen
lecker und punkt so unverschlüsselt
nennt sich die russische version der
burgerbrater stube jetzt
ich freue mich total über diese
eröffnung ich habe drei monate kaum
geschlafen und davon geträumt dass wir
aufmachen
es ist nicht ganz so viel andrang wie
damals im januar 1990 als der us fast
food riese seine erste filiale in moskau
eröffnete und natürlich tanzen heute wie
der micky maus noch rufe aber
die moskowiter haben lust auf burger und
fritten und genau das passt den
mächtigen gut denn die sanktionen
greifen langsam darüber kann weder die
neue frittenbude noch der heutigen
nationalfeiertag der tag russlands
hinwegtäuschen die isolation des landes
kommt im alltag der menschen an
lebensmittel sind teurer geworden
bei einer rente von 20.000 rubel etwa
330 euro merkt man das alles ist rund 30
prozent teurer geworden früher hat der
laib brot 36 rubel gekostet heute 64
rubel
das sind keine hohen preise das sind
schon haus hohe preise aber mich regt
das nicht auf glauben sie mir man kommt
immer irgendwie durch
noch sind die supermarktregale gut
gefüllt aber es gibt sie schon die
russische version der coca cola cola
zeitenwende beginn einer neuen realität
die viele betrifft
wir merken die sanktionen im
medizinischen bereich sehr stark uns
gehen einige materialien aus ich spüre
dass täglich im job es fehlt an
instrumenten und arbeitsmaterial
wird das irgendwann besser oder
schlechter die zukunft liegt im nebel
sie ist düster natürlich hoffen wir alle
das beste aber wird das auch ein treffen
momentan können wir nur wenige tage im
voraus planen
eine perspektive im dunkeln kaum
planbarkeit viel sprachlosigkeit putins
militärische spezialoperation
hinterlässt tiefe spuren auch in der
heimat
zum krieg und zur kriegsstrategie des
kreml finden sie analysen und
hintergründe auch online auftritte
erfolgte und jetzt macht erstmal ein
zweiter bleibt aber auch noch erstmal
beim thema der wegen der veränderten
sicherheitslage hatten finnland und
schweden vor knapp einem monat die
aufnahme in die nato beantragt aber die
türkei blockiert den prozess
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg äußerte
heute verständnis für die sorgen der
türkei bei einem besuch in finnland
sagte er wenn ein schlüssel verbündeter
wie die türkei bedenken hinsichtlich von
terrorismus äußere müsse man das
natürlich ernst nehmen und darüber
sprechen
die türkei wirft finnland und schweden
eine unterstützung von
terrororganisationen vor morgen wird
stoltenberg zu gesprächen entschieden
sein
bundespräsident steinmeier hat eine
debatte über die einführung einer
sozialen pflichtzeit in deutschland
angeregt es geht um die frage ob es
unserem land nicht gut tun würde wenn
sich frauen und männer für einen
gewissen zeitraum in den dienst der
gesellschaft stellen sagte er der bild
am sonntag
bundesfamilienministerin paus von den
grünen und bildungsministerin stark
watzinger von der fdp sprachen sich
dagegen aus mit einem pflichtdienst in
die freie entscheidung von jungen
menschen einzugreifen
nach der messerattacke an der hochschule
in hamm ist eines der opfer gestorben
die 30-jährige frau eine lehrbeauftragte
der hochschule erlag ihren verletzungen
bei dem angriff vom freitag waren drei
weitere studierende verletzt worden der
mutmassliche täter ein 34 jähriger wurde
gestern in eine psychiatrische klinik
eingewiesen
rund drei wochen nach dem massaker an
einer grundschule in texas hat sich eine
überparteiliche gruppe im us senat auf
vorschläge für einen besseren schutz vor
schusswaffen gewalt geeinigt dazu gehört
unter anderem eine intensivere
überprüfung von potenziellen waffen
käufern im alter von unter 21 jahren
us-präsident beiden teilte mit die
vorschläge enthielten nicht alle
maßnahmen die er für nötig halte gingen
aber in die richtige richtung ein
entsprechendes gesetz muss nun noch vom
us kongress verabschiedet werden
in genf hat vor dem hintergrund von
ukraine krieg und corona pandemie die
ministerkonferenz der
welthandelsorganisation
begonnen zu den größten streitthemen bei
den gesprächen der 164 mitgliedsländer
gehört eine patent aussetzung für corona
mittel beraten werden soll auch über
fischerei subventionen landwirtschaft
und ernährungssicherheit in
frankreich wird spannend bei der
parlamentswahl heute liegen regierung
und opposition aktuell gleichauf auf der
einen seite das wählerbündnis von
emanuel makro auf der anderen seite eine
allianz linksgerichteter parteien die
sich um den politikern jean luc
mélenchon verbündet hat ihnen ist es
gelungen die zersplitterte und
zerstrittene linke zu vereinen
ob die rechnung aufgeht wird sich
endgültig aber erst am nächsten sonntag
zeigen in der zweiten wahlrunde aber
thomas walde in paris für emanuel kommen
wir das heute zumindest auf den ersten
blick kein wirklich guter wahltag
also ist jetzt mich ein bisschen fort
was wir schon vor einigen wochen bei der
präsidentschaftswahl gesehen hatten da
hat man kaum am ende gewonnen aber mit
geringeren vorsprung als vor fünf jahren
das heißt die franzosen wollen dass er
regieren dass er regiert aber der große
optimismus für ihn das ist doch ein
bisschen verschwunden das setzt sich
heute fort die französischen sender
haben die bisherigen ergebnisse mal
hochgerechnet auf die künftige besetzung
der nationalversammlung demnach ist die
absolute mehrheit macros gefährdet er
muss womöglich mit einer relativen
mehrheit dort regiert das könnte er wenn
er sich partner sucht kann erfinden bei
den konservativen republikaner oder
einigen sozial demokratisch gesinnten
sozialisten aber er müsste dafür mehr
kompromisse eingehen als bisher worüber
sich hier in deutschland vielleicht
manch ein bisschen wundern bei der
präsidentschaftswahl im april war ja die
rechtspopulistin marine le pen als
stärkste konkurrenten aber die stille
jetzt keine große rolle
der grund dafür liegt auch im
französischen wahlrecht laut gesetzen
kann in den jeweiligen 577 wahlkreisen
am ende nur eine kandidatin oder einer
durchkommt der wird nach dem
mehrheitswahlrecht bestimmt das heißt es
werden diejenigen belohnt die vor der
wahl bündnisse schmieden die absprachen
treffen und dass er jon liebman chance
linkspartei mit den anderen linken
parteien den sozialisten den kommunisten
und den grünen getan die haben die
politische landkarte untersicht quasi
aufgeteilt wer wo antritt und wo nicht
und weil mir auch schon bei der
präsidentschaftswahl deutlich stärker
abgeschnitten hatte als die kandidaten
diese anderen linken parteien gibt er
jetzt dort in diesem neuen linken
bündnis den ton an die anderen parteien
haben sich ihnen quasi unterworfen weil
sie angst hatten dass wenn sie da nicht
mitmachen sie war sie überhaupt keinen
abgeordneten mehr am ende in der
nationalversammlung stellen können danke
steht thomas für die erklärungen
einschätzung jetzt noch mal andere
meldungen von heinz in berlin haben
zehntausende menschen dafür demonstriert
die bedingungen für das radfahren in der
hauptstadt zu verbessern auf zahlreichen
routen fuhren die proteste radler quer
durch berlin dafür waren viele straßen
gesperrt sogar die stadtautobahn mit der
sternfahrt sollten die berliner senat
und die bezirke aufgefordert werden die
verkehrswende umzusetzen zu der aktion
aufgerufen hatte der fahrrad club adfc
in der formel 1 hat max verstappen den
großen preis von aserbaidschan gewonnen
der niederländer siegte in baku vor
seinem red bull teamkollegen sergio
perez und george russell im mercedes und
konnte mit seinem fünften saisonsieg die
wm-führung ausbauen bester deutscher
sebastian vettel auf platz sechs
der zweimalige ddr fußballer des jahres
und kapitän der ddr-auswahl bernd
bransch ist tot wie sein langjähriger
verein hallescher fc mitteilte starb der
77 jährige gestern nach langer krankheit
brunch trug 72 mal das trikot der ddr
auswahl unter anderem bei der wm 1974
als kapitän der mannschaft
in elf tagen beginnen die finales
deutsche meisterschaften in 14
sportarten heute gab es in berlin schon
mal eine pressekonferenz dazu mit einer
reihe von spitzensportlern insgesamt 190
titel sind zu vergeben bei den
wettbewerben vom 23 bis 26 juni ard und
zdf werden die finales begleitung mit
mehr als 25 stunden programm und
jetzt noch wie immer sonntags der
ausblick auf die nächste woche in harte
christian ruff 5
[Musik]
wie viele soldaten sollen an die nato
ostflanke und sollen sie dort bleiben am
mittwoch beraten sich dazu die
nato-verteidigungsminister und zu der
frage welche nato-staaten weitere waffen
an die ukraine liefern können dazu
trifft sich auch die sogenannte ukraine
kontaktgruppe von 40 staaten auf
einladung der usa
wer führt künftig die afd beim
bundesparteitag in riesa will der
angezählte parteichef kino kuba wieder
antreten vielleicht mit
co-fraktionschefin alice weil es liegen
aber auch anträge für eine einzel spitze
vor dafür müsste die afg ihre satzung
ändern auch norbert kleinwächter
stellvertretender fraktionschef will
kandidieren wie der europaabgeordnete
nikolausfest die partei hofft auf eine
kehrtwende nach verlusten bei den
letzten zehn wahlen in den ländern und
im bund
kunstschaffende aus aller welt stellen
ab samstag wieder in kassel aus die
fünfzehnte documenta beginnt diesmal
kuratiert vom kollektiv europa aus
indonesien das für nachhaltige
ressourcen und kollektives teilen wird
die documenta kämpft allerdings gerade
auch mit antisemitismus-vorwürfen weil
unter anderem keine künstler innen aus
israel eingeladen wurden
und noch die wetteraussichten zum start
in die neue woche morgen im norden und
osten wechselnd bewölkt mit schauern und
gewittern auch am alpenrand anfangs noch
gewittrige schauer sonst freundlich mit
viel sonne bei lebhafter nordwestwind 16
bis 25 grad am dienstag bei 18 bis 28
grad im norden kompakte wolken aber
meist trocken im süden sonnig danach
zunehmend sommerlich mit viel sonne und
temperaturen bis 32 grad und passend für
den temperaturen geht für ein programm
gleich mit mord in midsomer weiter oder
0 30 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express und uns morgen wieder aus mainz
und riskiert so viele sind
[Musik]